podcast live and will be available after
the meeting
via the council's youtube channel
can everybody see me it just went off
screen
so can members
and officers please remember use the
raise hand feature
um mute your microphone when you're not
speaking
uh that will make the meeting hopefully
easier
if i if i can't see you and
um you you you can actually speak and
ask
to speak because sometimes you've got to
i can't see everybody on the screen
at once so i have to scroll sideways to
do that
we have four main items tonight
and a document has been provided for
each of the four
items for each item the executive member
or officer in attendance will give a
short introduction
to the item and will provide answers to
any questions
they have received in advance before
taking additional questions
from the committee so
i'll just before i start i'll just
welcome anybody who is
um looking in online um
and welcome to the meeting
um item one is attendance and
uh i have one apology and that's
counselor
new i don't know whether there's any
other apologies
that have been submitted no
okay i've got one from councillor heinz
right
okay thank you there any others
no uh item two is the
uh minutes of the meeting held on the
19th of august
uh can we approve them as a correct
record
no dissent i'll we will agree to approve
those
minutes uh item three declarations of
interest
this is on every agenda um if anybody's
got any interest to declare can they do
that
now
no
okay um dave oh right yeah
i'm sorry i did raise myself yeah i
couldn't see you sorry yeah
um no just to say that um i'm a trustee
of treat us
right yeah is there anybody else who
wants to declare can you can you speak
no okay um
item 4 is question from the public and
we do have a question
from a trafford resident which i will
read out
and it is the question is
my eldest son's year five
annual review didn't happen due to covid
none of his therapies happened due to
covert
his class bubble the second send
class in the school has been closed
from today as a member of staff has
tested positive
two therapists were due to go into the
school to see him today
that was cancelled if year six annual
review
is due next week there will now be no
assessment reports
that this and the review will be
cancelled
all year year six transition reviews
should be completed before october half
term so that secondary
places can be allocated no therapy
at all since march for my wheelchair
using sun x2
annual reviews not completed
my son and many others like him are
being forgotten
what is a plan to deliver health care
education
in a sats year and appropriate
place places transition for him
and his peers you cannot decide
secondary
education and support based on
year 4 information what is the plan
so that is a question um i don't know
whether we've got a verbal answer
tonight
um but i will ask um
karina or karen or jill to
to say whether you're able to give
a verbal answer tonight or
whether a written
response will be given um can i say
thank you for that pet to that parent
for getting in touch
um and we will pass it on to the
officers
um i'm looking at karen to see whether
we get a written response is that right
yes yeah i think karen's raised a hand
so
over to karen thank you thank you
council actor no it's just to confirm
because i think there's quite a lot of
detail so i think it warrants uh
quite a comprehensive written response
so we'll we'll produce that
um in in the very near future
yeah well thank you very much for that
okay so we now will move on
to item six which is the
active transport for this item we have
in attendance
councillor adzad the executive member
for
environment air quality and climate
change richard rowe corporate director
of place
and eleanor rove director of public
health uh i don't know who's going to
just introduce this um
is it richard or is it
steve
i don't not familiar with the procedure
because i wasn't briefed in advance
actually how it would be handled in that
sense of it
uh so i mean obviously uh i did actually
ask for the report
to work to members i think they
hopefully everybody has seen that now
yeah yeah members
do have the report so i don't know
whether there's any introduction
you know around it um do you want to
we're not considered obviously
it's in those points obviously uh
they've been asking a number of
questions and obviously hopefully
members have got the information there
but it's something that
we've been fully committed to over a
long time but especially now obviously
through this period of cohort we've
tried to do a lot of work particularly
around natural travel
and obviously the work that we've done
around the trance one and the challenge
two months and the original
uh emergency actually travel funds as
well
we're trying to get on this obviously
we've not been able to uh accede to
all the requests that members have
actually wanted in that century because
uh
obviously we do have a small uh traffic
team
in that sense of it uh quite probably
quite small compared to other
authorities
and with the timelines that were
presented from government
they then have to translate town to tfgm
and then
downstairs in traffic giving us every
little time to actually plan for these
things
so obviously where there's a lot more
things that we would like to do and i
think
i think i think the traffic team have
actually done quite a marvelous job in
that sense of it
and we need to thank them for that work
there and obviously we have the uh
the cycling along with uh a56 which has
been a
huge mammoth undertaking from everybody
involved there and obviously lots little
schemes around the brothers
uh including what the module filters are
just starting to go into place
now and as well as other little bits of
schemes that are actually being planned
and obviously we've got torrents to
stuff that they're actually looking at
in that sense right now
so there's been quite a lot going on
there in sense of it there in those
obviously as you've seen there from
parts of it there
uh obviously uh that you've seen the
answers to about the
20 zones there particularly because
obviously uh as part of it
there's a lot of work involved with them
and they involve lengthy consultations
with residents so it wasn't possible
obviously a normal
course of events it's actually it's
actually quite
an involved involvement from local
residents when we have to talk to them
about
how they want to see it and actually and
it can take quite some time there
wouldn't be time to actually fit that in
with it
in that sense it bad time to get it in
there and
obviously you've seen the report club
we're actually also providing uh
in the transfer of monies
looking providing some cycle storage
facilities and that's still being
finalized
and obviously once that's finalized and
comes out we've got the monies come
through from government on that one
confirmed
those will be able to position to
actually air uh that members have more
information about that one time that's
the one that one that's
under development there in that sense
right there uh
there's some interesting questions there
uh i think particularly uh
it does look at question four it's
obviously quite a problematic one there
it's always the question actually uh how
much weight did you listen to residents
and how much uh
incentive do you try and put things in
and hope that people accommodate it it's
one that's we've been uh
looking at for many many years and
obviously if you look at the model
filters themselves
often somewhere some sections of
residents have been very keen on them
in that center and they're going there
and others have been strong opposition
to it so it's actually uh
really working with residents and
actually shaping i think that's one of
the things
that has actually been not up to our
usual work in trying to
support residents in these games
obviously back to a lot of active
engagement with them
and there's not always been the time
with it obviously we put in the the
cycle lane down the a56 and indeed
other facilities uh without the normal
levels of consultation as well so i
think we have a mixture of things there
in that sense right there
and it's actually try and actually see
how we get on with it and and if it's
successful trying to carry on with it a
lot more
and uh but obviously uh there are some
things where
the uh some particulars of the module
filtered where there was actually really
strong opposition
and there's no case it wasn't this
opposition politicians say in some cases
there was actually clearly strong
concerns
around how it would impact on their road
uh an adjacent one so it
would simply be transferring some in one
instance from one road to the next
and i think that itself wasn't exact so
i think them in some cases it's actually
more a bigger piece of work there to
actually how we can actually solve some
of those problems
and in the time scale we've got it's
actually very hard to actually do that
so i think uh hopefully that looks at
those particular ones there
obviously a big section on the pavement
parking there and obviously you've seen
in the report there
obviously we are still awaiting some
powers from government there in that
century it's something that we do take
seriously
i myself that's sort of or many other
members have actually
looked at is where we have particular
problems in that sense we're vehicles
there
and something that we will continue to
look at and something that we actually
want to pursue but
on that point as well i would actually
like to add particular when you look at
footpaths particularly in residential
areas
uh it doesn't just cause a particular
problem there's a whole range of things
i mean look at if you go down many
residential areas you find
uh things for instance like uh hedges
that are massively overgrown
overtaking two sways of the footpath and
and these
uh even if they maintain these residents
do not simply cut them back enough
and they cannot take a significant
amount of the footpath and then we have
things like strawberry overhanging which
is a particular danger
for people who don't have a normal site
and they can be hanging down and they
may not see them coming
so i think there are some of the hazards
there and of course we have trees
both ornamental but also particularly uh
trees actually say should not
particularly be there
they can take over huge sections of the
footpath some places make them
unwalkable
though even in some cases it can
actually create things like where root
damage is evidence it can simply just
create it make
a lot of difficulties for people who are
trying to push buggies wheelchairs or
perhaps somebody who's got walking
difficulties down there
and over the summer particularly notice
a lot of problems with things like
builds materials
blocking up footpaths and they can be
quite a pain to get rid of as well and
we have to leave with highways on that
one
and then in many of our areas with
terraced housing we have problems
particularly with
lots of wheelie bins being left out
blocking foot after an ongoing basis
so i think that there's a big piece
there's a bigger piece of work there for
them as well and obviously whilst we do
take obviously
payment parking quite seriously i think
obviously i know particularly so we're
looking at the wider picture there
because it isn't just
vehicles that are problems there's a
whole host of things i think uh if we're
concerned about getting uh
taking this on board and actually
helping in this whole living we need to
look at this bigger picture because
uh some of these other things can be um
come i think
say can be more routinely missed by
people because you simply see them on
ongoing basis
and i think things like hedges you can
easily miss
but i think it's something that we do
take very seriously in that sense and we
look at them
but it's looking at that wider picture
there now tried to cover those things
there
uh particularly the questions but the
whole sense of it uh
look at active travel i'll just quickly
finish in a minute chair but obviously
on things like exciting obviously over
many years as council we've been never
supportive of that
and obviously we're fully committed uh
to the nurse challenge fund and
whatever will come in the future uh the
advantage with the mayor's challenge
fund is bringing for the first time
enabled to join up these routes she's
never been
able to do that in the past we're at
east local 40 over many years done their
own thing but now we're getting a
comprehensive network
drawing across the whole of gm we'll
actually link together and it'll be a
proper route for our cyclists to take
through a safe
uh and less congested routes and they
actually be more pleasant
and that hopefully encourage more people
to take up these take up
cycling in that sense of it so it's not
something that
it is something that we do take very
seriously and of course looks like
people actually do things like do more
walking as well particularly to like
local shops and make it safer for
children particularly for schools
uh indeed visit probably things like
local parks and others
and it's something that we want to take
up with challenge from another work
particularly with ernst we're looking at
the actual neighborhood and that's
actually going to be
our set piece to actually see as like a
model how we can actually
take these forward and actually we'll
that then replicate the number of areas
of other we know even across
gm that's going to be the biggest one of
the active neighborhood so i think
there'll be a lot of eyes watching how
it happens in urban areas
and there's going to be a lot of lessons
there to be learned for various actually
how it actually works so i think
we can be proud of what we are doing it
doesn't mean it's the end of it i think
if anything it's just the start of work
we need to do
but i'll leave it at that chat have you
got any particular questions from
anybody
okay yeah we've got yeah we've got uh
councillor
coggins and councillor john lam
at the moment but i'm sure that there
will be others so i've just
uh go off to councillor coggins
first yeah thank you chair and thanks to
the committee for
considering this is something i've asked
for a number of times
and there's a lot to welcome in this
report and in the progress that's been
made over the last few months
and the what does remain of the a56
route is
is is really to be welcomed and the
modal filters are coming in are to be
welcomed too
and i see there is promise of of hangers
and um
and and other things to come and i do
continue to worry that this isn't being
treated
as a directly relevant public health
coverage specific issue uh in the way
that it really should be at this point
in time we have to remember that these
measures have been brought in in order
to make it safe for people to travel
without public
transport that's one element but
crucially
we have to remember and we have spoken
to our director of public health about
this that
actually keeping people fit and active
and keeping people's body weight down
is uh two of the biggest things we can
do to help as many of our populations
stay safe through this next
few months or a year or two so um i do
worry that the council
don't consider this uh enough of a
public health issue and that's a bit of
an
add-on and that's not directly relevant
and anyway i did um the green group did
submit several questions about three
weeks ago although i don't we don't seem
to have had any reply
i'll go over and kind of the gist of of
them and a few others and i've also
spoken to um the
trafford cycle forum and i've um
incorporated some of their comments and
questions in what i have
and shall i do one at a time chair or
would you want me to hit
um the the first one is something i've
raised a number of times um
is about the comms um and the way we are
explaining this to people again
not perhaps explaining that this is
about public health but this is about
keeping people safe in a crisis
but also crucially um talking about the
modal filters
as being roads closed which actually has
led to a huge number of
misunderstandings and it's something
that continues to be done
even after we reported how many
misunderstandings are the modal filters
don't close the road they stop the road
being a true road so traffic can still
come
in both directions and park and turn
around
and and that just seems to be an ongoing
issue and i wonder is there
some way that we can adjust our comms um
to
to just make it clearer to people that
this isn't taking something away that
this is adding something extra
this is giving people safe and healthy
options
uh rather than taking something away
from people and in particular as well in
terms of comes
we know that and where these routes have
been put in elsewhere where they've been
really successful what's been done is
huge amounts of engagement
with um groups that are less likely to
take up walking cycling
because what's important about this is
this is not about the people who are
walking and cycling now
this is about the people who were
currently driving or had been using
public transport
and it's about enabling them to move to
walking and cycling
and and again in places like waltham
forest where really successful modal
shifts have happened
and what they've done is huge amounts of
engagement work and support
and encouragement for groups who were
less likely to shake this up so i'm
wondering
what has the council been doing or what
can we do in the future
to really get the message out there this
is a positive addition
to what we have on offer and to really
engage with the people
who might not have thought of making
this change
okay um
does anybody want to answer that
i mean i'll decide i think i think i
think the question really is about
communications
how how can we communicate and engage
with our
residents uh to to get them to
understand i think
and yeah i mean i think we take that on
board uh in that sense i mean part of
the problem with this was
uh i think i alluded to earlier it's the
timelines from this that were out of our
control
so it didn't meet our usual time period
for working with residents in that sense
of it
uh and i think obviously somebody comes
out there some of them have gone down
and somewhere has gone down really well
and been really supportive
and some of the areas uh i think
particularly where it was actually
moving like things like lorries around
to the other neighboring streets and so
it's not going down particularly well so
we can we can certainly improve comes
our discussions with the teams and see
how we can engage more
but i think with the with these
emergency monies it's been a challenge
to change
i think yeah i think we understand the
the the speed that you've had to do it
in because of the challenge funding
um yes but we do accept that we need we
could improve
i i think what's being said is is how we
really beef up the health benefits for
all
um i've got five other people who need
to to to ask questions uh council
coggins
um your other questions i'll be brief
yeah and obviously i i need brief
answers as well
shall i shall i hear you all my
questions and um
um on the um section 7.7 of the report
we talk about
20 mile an hour speed has not been
considered because of the time taken to
change the environment
but of course we didn't have to change
the environment before
the funding deadline we could have
brought in the 20 mile per hour speed
limits
immediately and improved it later on by
changing the deadline so i'm wondering
why that wasn't considered given that we
have in the past had old party support
for increasing the number of 20 mile an
hour zones in the borough
so that's one of them and the second one
is at section 5.6 really welcome the um
move to giving local authorities
enforcement powers for moving traffic
offenses
and i see that the council has plans to
do that and i'm wondering if specific
funding has been set aside
and so that when that comes through
we'll be able to do it
and question three is a specific one
about the a56 and actually the new route
um
if you are going north into town going
up turning onto the bridgewater way it
seems to be
more or less impossible i think unless
you're gonna cross four five
six nines of traffic or go all the way
back and around the very lethal
white city roundabout so it's not really
clear how that route works going
northbound
um and question uh the last one was um
what does council feel they have learned
from this experience and what can we
take forward
into the the next round of active
transport
um changes and changes to make our
streets safer and
camera yeah i i think you put the points
really well um and i i'm conscious of
the time and the other or the people who
want to to
to speak i think what what i will say
is that we can put all of those points
into a report
to the executive following this meeting
um and i hope you'll accept that
that would be useful as i said we did
actually submit several weeks ago a
number of questions
i know i i realize that but i think we
can make the point that you've made
to the executive that you know
we think that this should be done in
this
kind of way really so so i think we need
to do some work in in relation to that
otherwise
you know i think we could be here all
night with
just on this item and i need to go get
through the
um the other questions as well and then
we can record them you see
so i think that's the important point
and that then they'll go to the
executive
um so so council i've got councillor
john lam
councillor linda blackburn councillor
barry winter donnelly is there any
others
no right so um john lamb
uh thank you very much chair and uh
actually just to firstly welcome your
suggestion that um the comments we make
now on this on this issue
informs a report to go to the executive
i think that'd be a really good thing to
do and i would like to add to something
which has already been
alluded to and that is consultation and
the need to take residents along with us
uh in terms of the uh various schemes
that are being
uh proposed and indeed have already been
uh trialled
um i i don't think any of us would
disagree about the
benefits of cycling and
walking to improve health there's
loads and loads of data around which
would support
the efficacy of of that um
but we have seen with some schemes that
have been put in place already i know
there's been an issue about
uh time scales and what have you that
there's been
um you know a very strong reaction
against the
imposition of the cycling lanes the
implementation of the
temporary cycling lanes and i'm just
aware of
two proposed road closures which have
um generated quite a lot of comments so
i suppose
what we know already from that evidence
is that there are very strong views
which need to
be taken into account we need to
understand
uh what the business community
uh feel about some of these schemes and
certainly residents
have very strong views as well so in
terms of that report
uh chair going to the executive i would
hope that we would
all be able to agree that um
the engagement of uh with with uh
residents
and you know quite genuinely listening
to
their concerns and in addition
uh moving uh upper level to
okay so uh you know what what would they
propose
in terms of the objective of getting
people out
and active and so on what you know what
ideas do they have about the
neighborhoods which
they know and understand so it's not as
much a question
it's you know a suggestion that we
really emphasize that points in the
report
yeah okay thanks thanks for that john um
linda blackburn and and then cat
councillor
winston lee and then alan nero
so linda thank you uh could could i say
exact member
um how the safety of the
moving traffic has been evaluated along
the a56
since the temporary pop-up cycle lanes
have been put in place
and the reason i asked this was because
i was almost
involved in two road traffic accidents
last week
due to these cycle lanes thank you
um does the exact member want to answer
that particular question now not sure i
mean if
the uh council of blackburn cares to
send us the details i could certainly
have the points
in particular but as a general thing
obviously uh these are monitored on a
regular basis and it isn't just in this
season but
the work's been done by transport for
greater manchester so
every aspect we've done with this work
it's actually done with this with their
work and cooperation and then it's
actually their monitoring that actually
uh
helps us to develop the the next schemes
as we move along in this sense we've
always liaised with them on it
and they've always advised us on
particular problems that we deal with
with that particular black spots that
that being mentioned there and obviously
we're happy to look at that
this thing is something that we might
have missed or something that we can be
improved upon
but we're always happy to look at those
points chair okay
thank you ask chairman have uh transport
for greater manchester actually been
evaluating
the the actual uh movement of traffic
though
along that you know that main road
i can confirm that chair yes they have
on an ongoing basis since day one
thank you okay um
councillor win stanley the really quick
check that's been covered by all the men
all the members i think
and it's specifically on the fun on
consultation there's a certain
frustration with the
these emergency funds that we have to do
go with them very quickly and i share
counter-attacks frustration i think it
would have had more time
to carry out um a proper dialogue with
residents then some of the schemes which
we
binge now one in my own ward which is
not going to happen because of local
opposition
if we'd about more time for a proper
dialogue i think we'd have got something
through so i'm just really sharing all
the frustration counselor
said on the sureness of time we were
given for these consultations thank you
chair
thank you and
ellen hi i was just wanting to add from
a public health perspective obviously
you're going to understand that from a
public health perspective
i am you know really active travel is
one of the best things we can do
to improve our own health but also the
environmental health
aspects with covid we've had obviously
the issues around public transport
but also clean air and we were not
meeting our clean air standards
um before january we then improved but
our air quality is dropping again now
um equally you know we all know that
climate change is a serious issue for us
and
and trafford is um one of the areas that
is
um still over you know over producing
carbon emissions so
one of the well i absolutely absolutely
agree we need to be doing a lot of
consultation and making sure that these
these neighborhood-based schemes are
suitable for the residents and
um that residents are engaged in the
consultation we do have to have a way of
getting some of this traffic off
our streets that is not that's really
not negotiable
unless we can make completely different
changes to our lifestyles if we move
even if we moved all of the cars to
electric vehicles we would still
probably have some particulate pollution
so it really is about thinking with
residents it's not
um you know the time is now
to do to make these changes and covid
has put this into a very stark
perspective
particularly as i say relating to some
of the evidence around the
air quality and poor air quality adding
to
adverse outcomes from from kovid so
it really is trying to make sure that we
can provide that leadership
while listening to residents and
supporting residents to make some
some changes and behavior changes but
also in terms of businesses i think what
what the walton forest experience has
shown that
after initial opposition actually they
are seeing health benefits but also the
um the businesses
are also seeing benefits from this and
that often people have fears that are
not
um that do not come to fruition when
these changes are made
the evidence is that people who walk or
cycle actually spend more in local shops
so i think we just need to be um
listening and supporting our residents
discussing this
but really having a really frank
conversation about
what the alternatives are because
actually the current levels
of um petrol india's diesel vehicles on
our roads are not sustainable
um we won't be able to manage these
within the next
five ten years if we're going to get our
our carbon emissions down so we are
going to have to change our behavior and
we're going to have to start changing it
now
so it's how do we how do we get that
message and how do we give that in a
supportive way
because obviously some people will find
this very difficult but the
the mental and physical benefits from
walking and cycling
are phenomenal and the mental and
physical risks from driving
are also quite severe
thank you for that out helen um i just
want to bring in
richard rowe the director of place uh
just to um kind of
try and bring things together um and
because we
we don't have a lot left on this
particular eye a lot of time left on
this particular item so it's over to you
richard
thank you chair um just a couple of
comments and i won't go through the
questions in detail but counselor
coggins if you want to email me direct
with
with
your questions and i'm sure you'll get
i'll show you get a written response
uh as well as in advance of the report
going through to
executive i think just a couple of
comments um to make and without going
through the the timing issue but i think
if you look at the work we've done
around the elmston active
neighborhood and the level of
consultation that we've carried out
there which i think has generally been
very well received by the local
community i think that demonstrates the
approach that we are trying to
um take where we've got the ability um
to do that
as mentioned in the report we are
working on an active travel
strategy at the moment um the public
health team
and our leisure team are involved
in that so that's a broad piece of work
it's not just whilst it's coming from
place
it's a cross-authority piece of work
because we do absolutely recognize
the importance of active travel and if
you're pardon the pun
it is a journey we have been on for some
while so if you look at the
talbot road cycle scheme if you look at
the cycle city ambition grant
and the improvements to the bridgewater
where this isn't something new for us i
think it is about how we now to
take those um next steps um the waltham
forest is really interesting example of
uh of the approach absolutely agree that
we have to get
the consultation um right and the way in
which we
engage with um communities but as
eleanor said there are there are some
difficult conversations that we'll need
that will need to be added in order to
in order to deliver that and whilst i
recognize counselor
coggins comment that modal filters are
not necessarily
um closing roads and maybe our language
should be better
for some people that is actually we are
closing them to vehicle traffic
to through vehicle traffic and we also
have to make sure that we
that we're reflecting that um but we're
also positively engaging with businesses
about what it might mean
for businesses and how those businesses
can
improve um so i think it's a really
helpful
that it's come to scrutiny i think it's
a really helpful debate i think it's
really helpful that actually there's
much more discussion about active travel
now than there has been
um for some time and it absolutely will
remain
a priority um for us
okay thanks is everybody
okay with that and i
can move on to another item yeah
um that thanks to
richard and steve and eleanor
um for their contributions uh and we
will
uh try to capture all of this in that uh
report uh to to the executive
that we're going to do okay how can we
be excused now
thank you very much for coming along
much appreciated
as always yeah um
okay i'll go on to item seven now
and it's returned to school for this
item we have
in attendance um
karina carter who is the lead
member for children for education
um jill mcgregor who is a corporate
director of
children's services and karen samples
who is the director of education
and standards quality and performance
so um a report has been
circulated that fairly late um
but but it he did a short report and
uh i think there is quite a bit of
information on there
um karina did you want to kick
yeah i i i think you're right first of
all i want to say thank you to karen for
doing this report
and um the timing of it is that this is
such a fast-moving situation
but i've got updates from when karen
wrote this on you know over the weekend
um so as you know it was a government
directive that all schools would open in
september
and that is what happened in trafford
and we also had really really good
attendance
um much better we did fear um
quite a few parents might want to keep
the children off but that hasn't proved
to be the case
um and the first
the attendance is on the report and then
the next
item is around the amount of parents who
are home educating and i know yet again
this is a subject close to
geraldine's heart but we've seen quite
a rise which we did expect
and it's the same all over gm
so um we're keeping an eye on it we do
have an officer who's responsible
um and i've seen the sort of mapping
process
today that karen could give more details
about
how we look after those children who
aren't in school
you know obviously we might have
safeguarding concerns and
um you know we appreciate that some
parents
feel the need that they have to do that
at the moment
um the early years there's lots of
children now
attending those settings and 100 of
nurseries are open
um but we still have issues around
the breakfast clubs after school clubs
that wrap around provision
which has been a problem from since the
very beginning of the pandemic really
with the bubbles needing to be created
it's difficult for those operators
so as karen said we're going to sort of
keep an eye
on that sector but we do have some
concerns around that
the next bit i think's a bit that
members will be most interested in
and this is about the amount of covered
cases that we have in schools
and um so if you
um are a counsellor in a ward where
a school has had to send a bubble home
you will be getting a report on this
but since the weekend in this report it
says 23 schools
we're now up to 35 not necessarily
schools but incidents so some schools
have sent a couple of bubbles home
um and 10 of those are secondary
and yesterday there was a high school
that sent the whole of year 10 home
so i haven't done the running total
maybe one of the officers has it about
how many children
are isolating at the moment but you know
evidently we appreciate all the problems
that this brings
both the schools and staff and parents
who are having to manage that
um last week the dfe did announce that
there was going to be a helpline
that schools could ring but actually
we've had an absolutely excellent
service from trafford public health
who've worked really really closely with
schools so
we have encouraged schools to keep using
the local system
so just so we can have an oversight of
what's going on
um and and i think schools have been
really grateful for that
um there's lots of support i think has
detailed in the report
around um what how we how we're helping
schools
try and get back to normal and the
amount of staff we've got supporting
that
and maintaining the clusters of the
sencos have been particularly important
you will all know that we were promised
um funding catch-up funding
for the autumn term and karen's detailed
how much
we will be getting and this money is
going to arrive
in three tranches so schools will be
getting the initial
part payment this term there'll be some
more at the beginning of the new year
and then the next will be paid in the
summer term
and um you know we we would encourage
you all if you're a school governor to
scrutinize how this money is being
used there's more targeted funding
for language for early years and
well-being
which is obviously a priority of ours as
well and the final issue in the report
is school transport
and we do hold our hands up i think when
when it we first when the children first
went back
it it was difficult we had a difficult
couple of days
um just to let you know the magnitude of
what we're trying to deal with
we do 175 runs carrying
578 children and young people
and we do 18 runs carrying 45 adults
so it's an enormous amount of children
that we're trying to get around the
borough
and um part of the problem
um which still remains is the passenger
transport assistance
and the fact that um a lot of them were
are older people so they were shielding
um so we do have 130 staff working
and we have 10 volunteers from other
council services
and we have nine volunteers from special
schools who are helping to get children
to and from schools
um but it continues to be an issue and
there's a big recruitment
campaign going on to see if we can get
anyone else to
help with that so that concludes the
report thank you chair
can i just ask um in terms of the last
point that you made um what impact is it
having on the children in terms of
the transport not having passenger
transport support
and the other question would be for me
anyway
um the the the covered cases 905
children and 53 staff now i'm assuming
that they've not all
tested positive or have they or are they
just
self-isolating you know and can do
can you sort of define which ones out of
this
905 and uh 553 teachers
um because that would be useful to to
know
um i'm gonna ask karen to pick up on
your transport
um question dave it's actually one or
two
children from from every school it's not
many at all but obviously the either the
class or the year group have to go home
so the number's really high but the
actual number of children is really
small
but
no that that's fine thank you yeah i
think karina you've
you've said exactly you know that the
right thing that
the actual number of cases is low but we
do recognize that the wider impact is
significant
we've got a question and answer session
actually with our school leaders
tomorrow after school which is being led
by public health
and i think that's going to be the
perfect forum to just urge heads to
revisit their risk assessments once
again
just make sure because they ought to be
live documents um they need to be
evaluated
um and reconsidered in the light of
potential cases
but also we're going to try and urge
them to think about
some of their organizational and
operational issues too
um in so that we can try and minimize
the number of children that are being
sent
home in the bubbles and and try and
offer some kind of protection around
that it should be
um stated though that those children
that are in isolation that are
self-isolating at home ought to be
receiving some remote education
so uh schools are charged to make sure
that that's put into place
yeah thank thank you i noticed eleanor
uh ralph has um has just posted
um no we we are using the national
symptoms
list so hybrid temperatures persistent
cost
and loss change of
taste and smell um so so they're the
sort of guidance
um when children will be isolated
and so that's all part of the 905
yeah okay that's good right i've got
um linda blackburn
thank you chairman um if teachers are
unable to be
in school will there be any public
health issues if
supply teachers are moving from one
school to
another within the borough
i'm gonna say yes i think they will
linda and
and i know a lot of schools are sort of
working on
the sort of minimum teachers they can
get away with really
i think um not a lot of using supply at
the moment
but karen or jill might be able to to
say
i think you're absolutely right karina
schools are very reluctant
to bring in additional support from
supply teachers so they are
utilizing teaching assistance and
they're utilizing their current staffing
as best they can
however it ought to be um also i suppose
um we need to be reminded that the dfe
guidance does allow
for the use of supply teachers as long
as obviously they manage
safe working practice they're socially
distanced etc etc
um but yeah schools it's a last resort i
think for schools just to minimize risk
okay thanks um got barry wynn stanley
thanks thanks dave uh uh it was
it was a question well first of all the
general thing about the work that's
being done to
control this in schools my and it's
really it's a well done
trap of public health because my sun
school was one of the first i think to
start sending people home
and while at the start of the day they
were talking about advice from public
health england by the time we got the
end of the day they were talking about
the excellent advice they were receiving
from track and public health so
just a live example of the work that's
been done
uh in the section about with the
well-being education grant
that's to all state schools isn't it
that includes academies they counter
state schools still these days
that's the first first question and the
second one
is um when they're talking about
the five five local experts from the
educational psychology service cams and
vulnerable children's people
services are they is this additional
resource or is that redeployment of
resource from existing
uh from existing departments so in terms
of the education for well-being grant
yes
it's you know this the training it's
about using our local experts to train
and develop capacity in schools to deal
with the
emotional well-being of our young people
so it will be open to
to all schools um the five local experts
what yeah they're basically the staff
currently the tar in post
um in terms of the ask um
they will receive um an online a webinar
training session
so um a whole pile of materials and
resources have been supplied by dfe
that are then to be disseminated to our
schools to train up
um basically trade the trainer model
really and train up
people from within schools to to deliver
the support and create the provision in
the right kind of
um i suppose wrap around support for our
children at the moment
um what we are trying to do because
although the funding is there and it's
not entirely ring-fenced there are some
flexibilities about how we use it
um because we've already developed quite
a comprehensive we're calling it a
mental wealth
toolkit of support what we don't want to
do is replicate any of the existing work
that's going on in our schools
so we're absolutely utilizing it
utilizing it
as a kind of a complementary offer
for our schools it's a training resource
and then basically those members that
have been identified as
local um sort of practitioners or local
experts
will be there to offer advice and
support as they would do within their
remit of cams
eps or part of the education of
vulnerable children's service
so it's kind of a offer really to
supplement the work that's already going
on
so we don't see it as having a negative
impact on their ability to do their
current role
alongside you know becoming a local
expert
okay thanks um
so i've got account counselor rose
thompson
counselor coggins and counselor
jane dylan so um
rose thanks chair
thanks for the report but it was really
really interesting
just a quick question about the children
with ehc
plans just 13
have not attended school and i just
wondered if we've got any more detail
about
why that is are the these excluded
children or is it illness or
why that there was 13 not attended
thank you thank you councillor it should
be noted that those
figures are based on schools um
inputting the dfe return
so um that isn't um that isn't statutory
that isn't mandatory so for example
today when i've been on the attendance
return there's only 69 schools that have
completed it
so arguably those figures are not in its
entirety this is just the only
attendance data that we have access to
at the moment
so some of those children will be in
schools but they're just not recorded on
the portal information
um it should be stated though that we
have got some of our
our for example the orchards which is a
specialist provision
had to close those children will have
ehc plans
a small specialist class in barton club
have had to suspend their bubble
so again those children will have an ehc
plant and there were cases at delamere
so there could be the fact that the
bubbles suspended
um but equally um you know there could
be some anxieties and concerns
from parents particularly with those
children with really complex needs
that maybe just need a little bit of
time and support to you know to welcome
their children back into school
but what we are doing is we've opened up
the cluster of sencos and we're meeting
with our
certainly our special schools heads to
just um
ensure that you know we continue to
uh with if the children are in school or
not in school that they've got the right
level of support that they deserve at
this time
but at the moment when we do look at
some of our specialist provisions
they're certainly reporting some really
strong attendance figures
so i think it could be a whole kind of
con
complex picture of reasons why but that
could be something that
we can certainly have a look at and do a
bit more detailed analysis
of and and maybe bring a future report
to you that would be helpful
yeah i think it would be helpful and um
councillor coggins thank you very
briefly um as councillor carter
mentioned i do have a personal interest
in the elective home education
item uh although having checked um with
the legal advice earlier i was told
there wasn't a strictly declarable
interest which is why i didn't mention
the start and just that it does talk in
the report about parents requesting home
education and of course
um what actually happens is parents
inform the counsel that they're home
educating it's really important that
whoever is dealing with with those
parents
and is aware of that distinction
thanks for that um councillor jane dylan
thank you i was going to ask exactly the
same as counselor rose thompson asked
for also i've just got a couple of other
really short ones
are any families being fined for
non-attendance
and and also the laptops did every child
who needed one get one i know
that they were prioritized with looked
after children and
other things but i know there will be
some children in year 10 that
haven't got access i just wondered about
that please and just again on the ehcp
the children that are not attending do
we have any
children with ahcp's who are not now
receiving
all the provisioning part f of the ehcp
plans and that's it from me thank you
um as far as i'm aware we haven't find
anyone and
um our intention this term is to be very
supportive of schools
um i think i i can i can only
be um as clear as that um
that's right isn't it karen we haven't
yet that no we no we we
absolutely haven't and i think to be
honest with you heads are being very
sensible and very pragmatic about
um the authorisation of attendance and
absence i mean they're they're fully
committed to making sure that you know
we're welcoming as many children back as
possible
uh but we are absolutely not in a
position where where anyone is being
penalized as a result
um sorry your next was was your next
question about ehcps
is it laptops laptops yeah
yeah so um so counselor delivery in
terms of laptops yes off our first kind
of allocation was made to those children
who had a social worker and
those children obviously are looked
after children and are care leavers
we have actually had some additional
lapto
laptops left over so what we've done is
we've gone out back out to schools
and we've tried to identify last year's
year nines our current year tens
as a target group to again provide some
additional support particularly the
vulnerable
uh families and children who may not
have access to that or certainly
have to have shared access in at home
because again i think
with the whole exam situation and the
vulnerabilities around this year
i think that the current year tens are
going to be another vulnerable year that
we've got to keep an eye on so that's
where we've allocated some additional
resource
i think there has been some guidance
from dfe where schools can
um get get access to to laptops
themselves as well i think they've
opened up some additional resources that
schools are
are open to to looking into as well but
yeah we've also
capitalized on the the leftover laptops
that we had
in terms of um ehc plans i think for
those children who aren't in school
i think again council dylan this this
will be worth another investigation
another analysis
from our point of view from our team and
i think that's something that we can
pick up in a report going forward just
the impact of those children who aren't
in attendance and
certainly having a look at um you know
things around the annual reviews you
know we're conscious that um
questions have come in from a member of
the public around that
so we'll provide a detailed response
about our expectations on schools and
what the guidance that we're giving them
and also how therapies and health are
administering their duties and meeting
children's needs accordingly so
i think that's something that we can we
can certainly uh do an in-depth analysis
and bring a report it's a later date
that will be helpful
i have jill mcgregor
who who is um director of children
services so um jill thank you councillor
acton it was just to come back in on the
attendance question and
our approach i think it's fair to say
and karen was being incredibly polite i
think
that we have shared with the rsc
and dfe in our fortnightly react
meetings that
our approach will be to support to
encourage
and to do what we can to enable people
to attend school regardless of the
expectation from dfe and the measuring
against
the national average for attendance
because we recognize
it's a really complex difficult
situation and that we need to understand
individual circumstances and to work
with our
our pupils our families and our schools
so it was just to
reiterate that we're not taking a stick
approach to this that we are trying to
be
encouraging supportive and to look very
much at individual circumstances
thank you jim is there any other
questions before we leave this item
no can i just uh thank
um you know karen and jill
and um and karina
for coming along tonight and uh i think
the local authority and the public
health
i think have done a great job in in
supporting our schools
um you know i i'm a governor of
two schools and i know most count
councillors are governors of schools and
uh i think it's been an enormous
challenge um but i think you know
you've risen to the challenge yes there
are issues and there always will be
issues
and i think things change every day
practically every hour at the moment
um so so you know keeping up with that
is very difficult and i think um
my thanks also go to uh you know all the
um the schools the teachers uh the
support staff
and you know all the staff that work in
schools
uh i think have done an absolutely
fantastic job
uh in in in meeting that challenge
so that's just comments from myself and
can i thank you
very much for coming tonight much
appreciated
thank you chair um
can we now move to item
eight which is um the finance
update and i think um
we we have uh councillor ross who is the
executive
member for finance and investment and
nikki bishop the corporate director of
finance
and systems and we did receive a quarter
full report and also uh
a presentation um on
on the uh situation the financial
situation
um and update uh so so
um is it over to you
tom councillor yes thank you very much
chair and good afternoon everyone um
it's good to be back at exclusively i'll
just take you through
this presentation and then i'm very
happy to take any questions so
uh alex next slide please
can you just say that all right yeah bro
right so first of all if we go
through the updated position for this
budget year um at the top you'll see
that we've estimated the
gross covert 19 financial pressures as
being
45 and a half million pounds
in the next um next row you'll see that
how this has been met so far so this
includes
government grants a ccg contribution to
hospital discharges and ppe
um the support for lost say
sales fees and charges income which
we're estimating to be
three million pounds um a transfer of
the collection deficits
for council tax and for business rates
into the following
budget years and use of specific
reserves that brings
the balance down from 45 and a half
to 8.3 million for this year and
as you'll have seen from the budget
revenue monitoring report that was
published recently
we're looking at a projected saving for
the year
at this period of just over 6 million
that leaves the gap anything between
2.2 million for this year and 8.3
million
now you'll note from the revenue
monitoring report that we're
estimating an overspend of 2.24 million
in that report which we'd look to bridge
that gap using
reserves however you'll see it's in
small print at the bottom of this slide
but it should be in much bigger print
now
this just assumes that there's no impact
of a second wave
um on on this current situation
and you'll see from restrictions that
are being announced today that
actually things may get a lot worse
again this year we don't know yet but
that's my feeling
anyway next slide please uh alex
just to set the scene this is the um the
the updated budget gap
for the forthcoming few years so you'll
see
that the uh the pressure for next year
it's one something that i mentioned at
the uh the previous
scrutiny committee that i attended which
is 35.1 million
now that can be broken down into two
different areas
we've got business as usual costs there
which i'll go into shortly which are
about 19.2 million
and we've got the uh covered related
costs which again i'll go into
um of 15.9 million and
the split here informs the approach that
we make as we look at the
the next budget year next slide please
thank you okay in terms of the budget as
usual gap
the lines on here which include
demography
include pay inflation um
reversal of use of reserves from from
this year
they all add up to the um 19.2 million
at the at the bottom of the slide and if
we move on to the next slide
we will see the ongoing covert pressures
which include the loss of the airport
dividend
ppe costs uh fall in the council tax
collection rate um falling business rate
income
um so at an additional pressures demand
blood pressure say in the adult social
care budget so that leave that's the
15.8 million there
um if we move on to the next slide which
gives you a summary for the years ahead
as best as we know it i should say and
what we're looking to do here is
look at one-off ways of meeting the
recurrent covert pressures so they could
be
reserves or other factors but look at
how we can identify
savings for the businesses usual
pressures of 19.2 million
as we go on to the next slide it takes
us through to the savings identification
so you will see that the the gap that we
have to um bridge
is huge um for this next year um
every corporate director has been
looking at savings and identifying
savings in their potential areas
um the executive have had over the
summer a number of workshops
and given an input and we're looking to
put together the uh the draft budget
report imminently
you'll see that we've already launched a
voluntary severance scheme
um that was launched earlier this month
and unions have been involved in the
sign off for that before
in the putting that together before it
was signed off by a recent employment
committee
and if we go on to the final slide we've
got the next steps
so not long now until the draft budget
report is published on the 1st of
october
it will go to executive on the 12th we
will then have a
budget consultation period which will
carry on
we'll get set up from october into
november
budget scrutiny which will be incredibly
important as it has been every year but
more so this year given the the savings
we have to find
those sessions will take place in
november and december
all being well we may have some good
news about the spending review in uh in
november possibly into december
and likewise the local government
finance settlement
before we present the final budget for
next year in to the council for approval
in february
2021 and i'm not happy at this point
to take any questions that may be
thank you for that tom
very helpful and uh and thank thanks for
the report
uh the the presentation report that you
uh sent out which was helpful as well um
right i've got uh counselor linda
blackburn
um linda okay
thank you chairman could it just ask
about the voluntary
uh sovereign scheme uh is this actual
redundancies and as such um how many
jobs do you expect to go next year
because of it
okay thank you for that question this
isn't a redundancy scheme it's a
severance scheme and it's voluntary
at the moment we're looking at ways that
um staff who wish to work more flexibly
or wish to come to a mutual agreement
with the authority
to depart um trafford we're looking at
ways of bringing that together which
would obviously bring
some savings for our budget lines for
future years
but at the moment we are focusing on the
voluntary side and severance
we are not contemplating other
redundancy measures at this point in
time
though that may change but they just
ask will there be any
reduction in the number of personal
assistants who
who are there to help the uh children
who
we take to school in the mornings and
after school
or well those numbers still remain the
same couldn't really comment on an
individual line like that linda
obviously they play a very
important part in what they do but we
would we would have to look at that if
we came to a scheme
at the moment we're focusing on a
voluntary
set of flexible working patterns and and
severance so we've not at that stage
um linda
okay um her account counselor judith
lloyd
judy um
i was looking at the quarterly report um
and obviously
you've um put some contingencies in
particularly for the
high need budgets and i noticed that um
there's been an accret increase
increasing children in need
and and sorry i just
lost the other one for now and although
you've got
a reduced in placements what's
um i suppose i'm concerned about that
and the fact that copic cases are rising
and therefore that puts pressure on the
social um the social services budget
as well um given the news today as well
about more restrictions and everything
how comfortable are you
um with the contingency that that you've
put in place
and will we need some more again a
counselor
that's a very good question these are
the best estimates that we can put
forward at this stage um
it is going to be it's going to be very
likely that i'll keep coming back to
this committee with different sets of um
of figures as and when things change and
obviously we had a very big change today
with the set of restrictions and
we have always been open in the fact
that covid
will have an impact on our demand-led
budgets and the the impact on both
adults and children's
so this is the best estimate that we've
got at the moment
i completely acknowledge that it could
change within weeks it could change
within months
i i hope that it doesn't but i have to
be realistic i don't know whether nikki
or jill
would wish to come in and talk a bit
more about those particular budget lines
as well at this point so jill had a hand
up to to come in
uh anyway but maybe she'll answer that
or try to answer that as well just
just in terms of the monitoring of our
demand-led
pressures and the mitigations and
actions that we have
both myself and diane who'll be able to
speak from an adult perspective
we closely monitor what the demand looks
like and what the needs are and
we obviously have active conversations
about
what strategies we can have in place to
try and manage that
and what that might mean for the budget
line but
it is fair to say that they are volatile
budgets at this moment in time
um so in june for example we had nearly
a 48
increase in terms of initial demand at
the front door
um which is working its way through the
system
but making sure that we have the right
staff with the right skills to
manage the complexity of needs is a
critical part of that strategy
okay thank you thanks for that
um are there any other questions
um if not i i i've got a question
um and it's um
it's going to the going back to the
um uh the
um the report the the big report the
yearly
report the uh uh
item what is it um
budget monitoring yeah yeah it's a
budget monitoring yeah
yeah sorry sorry um and and it's a
financial
pressures uh and i look through those
pressures um uh the you know the
the loss of income um and
uh it you know includes parking fees
uh property lettings uh outdoor media
advertising planning fees
building control fees licensing
highway permits
street trading and
also the council support to uh
trafford leisure um and the whole
totally is 6.2 million
pound and i suppose the question is
when when do we start charging people
for you know what they normally pay for
parking and
planning fees and
all of those kinds of things which
it seems to me that um yeah we've got
covered but life is still going on
and there comes a point when there needs
to be a charge i would have thought but
i might be being very naive in in terms
of that and i don't know what the
regulations are
um but but i i wonder what
sort of discussions have been had in
terms
of that okay well you'll recall there
was a suspension of various fees
at the start of the outbreak um
those things to the best that most have
kind of been coming back
into play um as as the first wave
calm down however i think the um the
page nine that you refer to in the
report it's a very sobering read it just
shows how valuable
lots of fees and income to the council
are and a lot of it will be reductions
in demand
so for example people won't be parking
as much
in town centre car parks and there'll be
other things like
planning will be put on hold various
other things that people would
you know propose to do or stored because
of the
the kobe situation and that's obviously
hit the council's income
quite badly now you you'll note that the
government has agreed to meet us
part way with um with income that we've
calculated to have lost our estimates
are that that would be about
three million pounds you'll see that the
um i mean i'm talking crude figures here
but you'll see that 6.2 million pounds
that we've uh we've estimated to a lost
from fees and income so
there's still a gap that we we need to
find ourselves as we um
as we we bridge the um the current gaps
in this budget but
yeah i think that the the the thing i
can say about um
about that is because it did stand out
when i uh when i saw that part of the
the report is just how valuable
fees and income are to the council and
without those fees and incomes
we don't have as much to spend on our
frontline services
yeah yeah so at the moment then
um it is that we're not back to normal
in terms of
of some of those issues around car
parking and planning and
and so on yeah but yeah
yeah i think with which uh there's just
been a huge
demand shock probably the biggest
we've ever seen well it is the biggest
one if you've seen the if you look at
how
gdp collapsed this year we've never
lived through anything like this
and it just reverberates through
everything
that we we we do and see and it
certainly hits
this council and many other councils
whether you look at the um
the functioning of the airport and the
loss of the dividend there
the collection the fall in the
collection rate of council taxes people
unfortunately find themselves out of
work because of the um
the the impact on the economy there's a
whole
range of things that this this covered
situation has uh
has caused you know to people in the
economy and and it's
a huge financial hit for the council
and we're not out of it yet by any means
as
we've uh as we have seen from the health
figures and we've seen from the
the restrictions today which will have a
further impact on the economy sadly
yeah yeah thanks for that tom um
i've also got uh barry winston lee
uh councillor win stanley and richard
rose so
um over to you barry thanks dad well
more on an observation of the question
really i thought the first observation
is i'm
impressed that tom and nick and the rest
of the rest of the team can turn up at
these meetings and still crack a smile
because i think i think thank you having
i think the pressure under is just
absolutely staggering absolutely
staggering
and i also feel so abandoned not by
youtube but by
central government because we are
splurging billions
at a national level and yet i know that
local authorities of every stripe
are um are screaming for help
and i could be wrong but it appears
before the falling on death ears i mean
you said only part away were being
covered by central government but i
remember various government ministers
standing up in march in april and
telling local authorities do what you
need to do don't worry about
it and it just says just an observation
it feels like we've been abandoned
there's no it's not a political point
conservative councils are making exactly
the same point to central government
and it's a cause of deep frustration to
me
i'll finish by again saying to tom and
nicki the rest of the team excellent
work
keeps saying keep saying all these crazy
times
thank you thank you very much for that
uh barry i appreciate it and
yeah it's not gonna notice with me the
uh the amount of money that uh the
government
seems to be wasting a lot of it on the
private sector i
i dare i say um in in um
in trying to tackle the uh the coverage
situation where actually a local
solution
um if you look at test and trace being
an example a local solution
would probably bring much more effective
delivery of test and trace a much better
value for money
um you're right that we did anticipate
now remember way back in
off last live as it were meeting
of the exec in march i did believe that
the government would do all it takes to
support the councils i am disappointed
but still hopeful that um come the
spending review
and uh and and and come the um you know
what what is divided up for us at the
end of the year that they'll deliver but
it doesn't look like that at the moment
the whole burden sharing narrative
is is very worrying and i do believe
that national government don't
understand the
amount of services that we deliver as a
council and
just how valuable and important they are
to residents
across trafford and we've got to make
sure that they're properly funded before
you know we're at risk of losing them
forever
yeah um oh richard rowe
that's uh uh it was just on the back of
the comments around fees and
charges so for example on planning we
have not stopped
charging uh people for making planning
applications we still do what we have
seen
is a a switch in the type of
applications we're getting so we're
getting a smaller number
for major and household applications we
have seen a significant increase in
in people applying for orders to do
works to
trees for which there is no fee but
still takes up an awful lot of
um staff time same on car parking income
as has been mentioned this is
our town center car parking income is
demand led we've seen fewer people going
into town centers a significant drop in
footfall
um over the corby period and it's still
not got back yet
to where it was previously
pre-coded and also some of our
commercial estate where we've seen
a challenge on rental income so this
is shops that we've the authority has
held for for many many years separate to
our investment
estate um where again we've seen tenants
struggling to pay for
for obvious reasons and that's causing
us an income challenge as well some of
which
may well be deferred we may be able to
pick up but others where actually we
know we've got tenants who are
going to struggle and to repay any debt
that we've got
yeah that's it thanks i think that's
really helpful
are there any other questions
no i can i thank
you tom um councillor ross
and the director for coming along
tonight
uh much much appreciated um
and uh i'm sure that we will be
uh seeing you again in the not too
distant future
um clearly what once you've
uh looked in the and the executive has
looked
at uh producing a budget report for
um for next year and
um you know we we will be looking to
scrutinize that and i think we've
got a a couple of meetings uh scheduled
later in the year um so so can i thank
you for
giving us that update uh i think which
uh
i think the report that you gave or the
presentation that you gave uh
i i felt it was um a lot clearer
uh and you could see um you know
at a glance really what the issues are
and i'm grateful for that uh yeah i
think if if
if we need further information then we
we we can dig deep in into
uh all the reports um but i think uh
for this meeting it was very helpful
um so thank you again um both of you
for coming along tonight uh and again
it's
much appreciated thank you we'll see you
next time yeah we'll do
thanks though um okay
uh we'll move on to item
nine um and this is a public health
update uh and we have uh in attendance
uh councillor uh slater
the exec member for health and
well-being
and equality and eleanor
who is a director of public health
i think um counselor joanne harding
um is here and uh
diane heaton um who is um
who is a director of adult care um
so i don't know who's eleanor
oh are you jane yeah are you kicking off
thank you yeah thank you chad just like
to thank um ella and the team for the
report that's actually before us this
evening and you know the staff are
working flat out
and on on the stuff that they're doing
around
their track and trace and the paper it
outlines what's happening in traffic
over the last
few few weeks and it's um and it's
looking at you know
community engagement and all the things
that we need to get right so that people
are listening to the message and keeping
keeping as safe as we possibly can in
traffic and i think that
i i was late coming onto the call and
chair because i i
had work and apologies for that but i
wasn't um
it's donna and and helen collins on the
call
yeah yeah because i think
i think we're going to move to donner
and helen um
this on this occasion and then eleanor
can uh do the mop up if need be
and because i think we have quite a lot
of questions for donna and helen last
time i think we
sort of like ran out of time so
helen to give you some updates on track
and trace and and
and what we've been doing thank you
so if donna starts with them testing but
just as a quick summary
um you'll have seen our figures have
gone up unfortunately
we've now got 50 over 50 cases per
hundred thousand
we've got cases in every ward um
i mean the nationally you will have seen
obviously nationally the figures are
increasing
we are comparatively doing um better
than
other areas in greater manchester but it
it we're still in a very very precarious
position i would say in trafford at the
moment
and our figures are increasing and we
will see those
looking at the data we're getting
through we are going to be seeing our
rates go up
if i ask donna to just say a little bit
about what we've been doing on testing
and then helen
to talk for a minute on uh the track and
trace
because i'm sure people will have a lot
of questions on those yes
thank you thank you chair um
i just wanted to give a quick update in
terms of the testing program as you know
tierra our ambition was to have a range
of testing opportunities
uh in trafford um and we've had mobile
testing units throughout the borough
we've also got a site in partington and
we've got a site at trafford park
which all of which are incredibly busy
um i think everybody who reads the news
is aware that we've
had enormous pressures in terms of the
testing programme
um because of a huge demand for people
to be tested
and um and it's been a it's been a
really difficult time for those
residents who've tried to get health
tests and not been able to
um we are obviously very sympathetic to
the
to that system but it is a national
system chair and we can only rely
on the um predominantly the the backlog
is due to lab capacity
and we have been informed nationally
about the
opportunities to expand that lab
capacity which
hopefully will then relieve some of our
really
testing challenging issues that we're
facing at the moment
um i wanted to thank and support all our
care homes who are working incredibly
hard at the moment
to uh offer testing on a very regular
basis to their residents and to their
staff
unfortunately they too are experiencing
some difficulties
in terms of getting the results back in
the meaningful time that they can then
support some
proactive work with their residents i
spent most of today
trying to find some results from some of
our care homes which
which were they were struggling to
access um
and similarly our schools um all have a
very very small supply of testing kit
for themselves
um to hand out to those families who
find it incredibly difficult to reach
a testing site but that's very small
numbers and they are experiencing delays
in terms of trying to reorder those
so at the moment i think the testing
sites
in trafford will remain um and that
that's a good
good position for us to be in but the
key issue for us is how we can
make sure that our residents can access
those testing opportunities
when they have symptoms of covered
i think thank you very much for
for that um is there any questions in
relation to the
testing um yeah counselor
hayden williams hayden thank you
and a thank you to um councillors later
and also
to donna for their comments yeah um i
just wanted to
express um on behalf of the book club st
martin's world council as our own thanks
for the work that the public health team
have done
in establishing the partington testing
site
um the communication with us throughout
has been absolutely
um stellar and i think ben wilmot in
particular has done some
fantastic work with resident engagement
so
and trying to assuage concerns that some
residents have about
uh people coming into the testing center
and
in in the immediate area so i think
phenomenal work and
i really am appreciate it and i'd like
to put that on the record
um really in terms of the testing and
the cases that we're seeing
i was just wondering i think a previous
pandemic scrutiny committee
um i talked about whether or not we were
capable of
circulating data relating to
hospitalizations and i think
at the moment we're still not really
seeing that in the um
weekly um sort of uh briefing that
circulated
to members and i i just again sort of
query that because
i think recently um on news night
there's been a couple of pieces about
the distinction between a positive test
result
and then whether um that subject goes on
to develop symptoms or
to become a true case in that sense
and i'm just wondering whether or not
that is something we can look to
circulate and i think
the other thing i wanted to say there is
that it's really promising that um
we're still not seeing any big outbreaks
in our care homes
um and then lastly i just also wanted to
ask about
um there's a corresponding report about
our preparedness for a flu season that
was circulated
to to members as part of the agenda and
in that report quite a few of the
medical practices appeared to have
um expressed concerns about supply
shortages of the vaccine
and i think the report itself
acknowledges that that's quite a big
risk factor
um now it does seem that we're a few
weeks into
um well a few weeks since the report was
prepared
and i was just wondering if i could
query if there is any indication that
we're going to have
concerns around the availability of the
vaccine as we're entering
flu season thank you thank you
[Music]
donna did you want to come back on those
those points i think eleanor will be
able to give an update
in terms of the hospital admissions and
also the flu season
um so she might be able to give that
update now yeah oh
okay and i think um
i think the care homes um
you know there's been a lot of news
uh in in relation to the care homes and
i think uh
some of the news that i've seen is that
the the
not not in traffic but
seen has been uh kind of
negative in terms of the concern that
you know we we could
go over what what went previously
in in terms of um the government
seems not to
[Music]
factor in care homes very much
in terms of the testing and so on
um but i don't know how we're doing in
in traffic so
that would be useful to to know
um but but if we just deal with the
uh hospital admissions first
what we can do is we'll we'll try and
add the hospitalization data into the
data set
um it's just worth bearing in mind that
the hospital any hospitalization is
usually
quite a while after the initial
infection so most people would take at
least two weeks
typically about two weeks before they
were hospitalized and also
because of the age profile of the people
that we're seeing testing positive now
we wouldn't expect so many of them to be
in hospital we're seeing very few people
testing positive
in over in outside the working age
population
um so those people we wouldn't normally
expect to be
hospitalized unless they had underlying
health conditions
so but that is very much a figure that
we are looking at and we will
we will um share that in terms of the
flu update
uptake obviously um we are really i mean
the gps are working incredibly hard this
year to try and make sure that they get
really good coverage and we are
imploring people to take up the offer of
that flu vaccination
um it's starting already um and
we obviously people um the people of
age 65 and over and people with chronic
conditions pregnant women
and small children are prioritized the
schools program
is about to start as well and um
obviously i mean i do feel for the head
teachers
because they have so much on their plate
already but we one of the things we'll
be talking about with them
is making sure that we can get good
uptake um for the flu
program in schools this year because we
really do not want to have flu
circulating at the same time
that we have covered so um really
anything that
any of uh viewers elected members can do
to promote
the uptake of that flu vaccine will be
very gratefully received
um because of the logistics of
delivering it this year
um with the social distancing and so on
in the gpu practices
um there will be the gps will be doing
quite a strict schedule and calling of
patients um rather than asking people
just to drop in
so the other thing is um to say to say
to people
you know we we are very very keen people
we will be getting an invitation to be
um immunized but please do make sure
that you go at the point that you're
asked to go and
arrange your appointment at that time
rather than turning up
on spec because that will you might be
turned away and that would be a wasted
journey
um but really we do want to make sure
that we get that flu vaccination
up and running not least because um
there are well with you know obviously
we're still waiting to find out about
the covid vaccination
but some of the um vaccines that
um are being developed you have to wait
a certain amount of time after having a
flu vaccination before you can be given
the code with vaccination
so the sooner we can get everybody with
their co
flu vaccination then we'll be able to
have a clear run at getting that covered
vaccine
um if and when it appears um
in terms of the care homes i know diane
and donna will say more but
the um we have been working it very hard
with our care homes and our care homes
have been
absolutely amazing throughout this
they've worked so hard to keep
keep their residents safe and to and to
really try and make sure that um they
have a good quality of life as well
um and so we have been working very very
closely with the care homes throughout
and trying to make sure that they get
all the advice and support that they
need
um but i'm sure diane would want to say
more on that one
okay can i just bring in councillor
harding because she
mentioned on the chat that she she'd
like to come and
give us an update really on on the and
uh i think really that i i just wanted
to mentor
her that as she raised it uh raise the
issue specifically
i'm sure that many of you will have been
made
aware or will have seen the news article
that went out on channel 4 news
on thursday um which
gave quite a um painted a worrying
picture that trafford were placing
covered positive patients into care
homes
it was quite um misleading and
misrepresentation of the facts actually
and um
i've sent a briefing out to all members
a briefing has gone out to
to care home providers and also to
families who have
loved ones in care homes too because it
was incredibly distressing
for people to see that people each
document there was
um a document as a contractor gone out
for the contract for
discharge to assess where we work very
hard to try and make sure that people
aren't in hospital
that we discharge people to assess them
to look at what their next destination
may be
national guidance is that everybody
leaving hospital has to be tested anyway
and just to remind people that trafford
were actually doing that
back in march which traffic were an
outlier and we have always tested
patients before they have left
hospital so we are not putting positive
patients into care homes we're working
very closely
with our providers to look to see how we
provide the best support
and not withstanding really we do have a
duty of care
to look after our patients that that
have potentially had 2 some of those
people
would be very poorly residents but we
work with providers
but i just want to offer reassurances
because the last thing we need like the
call that i took on thursday evening of
an 80 year old lady 85 year old lady
actually
who called me incredibly distressed
thinking that
you know we were actually putting
positive people into care homes
when stories like that go out it
you have to remember there's a human
element to this
and it's incredibly distressing if
people aren't armed
with the facts and also remember that
throughout this pandemic
some families haven't seen a family
member for six months or more
and you'd have seen the late
his restrictions announced today it
looks like that's going to be an ongoing
thing too
so we are working i'm working very
closely with diana and all her
dedicated and excellent team across
social care the same with eleanor and
all her colleagues across public health
and we are committed to ensure that our
care home sector
stays safe if any of you do have any
concerns as you know i'm always
accessible
very happy to talk that through we prep
we're preparing a winter plan now
for social care and what i would like to
do is table a paper and bring this to
pandemic scrutiny ahead of winter so
that you're fully sighted
on all our plans and you know exactly
what we're doing and are very open to
scrutiny of that plan thanks chair
[Music]
thanks very much for that joanne that's
very helpful
um i know karen barkley
councillor karen barkley would like to
ask a question
[Music]
yeah thank you chairman and thank you to
uh donna
and elena for the update and um you may
have already covered this when you were
looking at school sorry i came in late
also because i was working
and i just wanted to know about the
situation of
tests available to school children
whether traffic schools
have sufficient and how we're actually
dealing with children
who are who are in need of tests and
obviously you know
the fact that we now have to ration them
thank you chairman
okay we have touched on
testing but uh elena if you've got
specifics on that
[Music]
helen helen is has been doing all of
this but we have we
are having issues with um with the
schools and the
ability of families to get tests and
some of the schools have used i think
all of their um
pen kits already and but and have been
told that there will be
a substantial delay to getting more so
we are having difficulties in accessing
tests for everybody who needs them
um helen i think can give a little bit
more detail on that
helen
um were initially given a small
um pack of tests to use for children who
they would consider more vulnerable or
less likely to be able to access testing
and for some school staff as well
a number of our schools have run out of
those already and have reordered
but they've been told i think a 21 day
um
delay in accessing them but what has
been really helpful is public health and
then working with the localities has
come up with a criteria
so that when we're informed of a child
who has
covered symptoms but cannot access a
test
then we work with the school to
determine the likelihood that that child
is
a probable covid and then what the
action should be as a result of that
rather than waiting and waiting
for a test result or a test to become
available for that child
so this allows us to act really quickly
so we've had
a high school for example where they've
had a number of uh
kids in the class already so two cases
of positive
and a number of others that were
symptomatic we've been able to work
through those symptomatics quickly
to advise their families and to advise
the school in action
so the criteria it's not a test it's not
a test result but the criteria is really
helpful
in helping to reduce the transmission
risk
okay are there any other questions
that i think we probably
would want to know a little bit more
about the tracing
element so um contact tracing
yes contact yeah so um
it's an interesting role to be and i
would say it's changing every day at the
moment but um locally so we work very
closely with the gm
um training hub and they've experienced
some significant
um pressures over the last two weeks
that have kind of had an impact then
onto the localities
but we have two types of contact tracing
in trafford
one is the the level um two which
are the people who've not been contacted
yet by the national team
who need to be contacted and then
we have the um complex settings as well
so um the level two one is working
really well at the moment
demand is far higher than we anticipated
though but what we would say is
our team one moment sorry
our teams are brilliant in terms of um
the contact they've made so where the
national team perhaps hasn't been
successful
we've managed to contact 70 of the cases
that have come through the local
um contact tracing um
service so that's been really good um in
terms of the ongoing nature of that we'd
initially had a model which was the
spock team
with three contact traces across the
seven day week
but now we're actually looking at a
model where we're integrating it into
access trafford
we're training up access traffic staff
so we'll have four staff
um in the shifts and this allows us to
build resilience in and allows us to
manage any peaks and troughs as well in
demand
and it also has it uses the trafford
branding and
um the staff members of access traffic
are used to having conversations with
residents
and tricky conversations at times so it
looks like a really positive model
and we'll be going live with this from
next monday so that's really good
um we've also worked around surge
capacity because what we've seen from
bolton and other areas is the sudden
increase
it means that we need to um mobilize
stuff to support that
so um diane's team and members of the
ccg
we've got 60 staff on standby for surge
capacity
and and so we can access those from
again the 28th
of september when we anticipate that
their training
will be um complete and they will be
able to access the ctas
system so that's looking really good at
the moment we're just working through an
out of hours process which
hopefully will be in place by the end of
this week as well so that's the local
contact tracing
in terms of the complex ones which the
spot was set up to originally do
it has been busy we are seeing
workplaces
um coming through but what we also
notice is the workplaces
the workplaces that engage are doing
really well in terms of
being able to support and that contact
trace within their workplace
our biggest pressure point is within the
school setting at the moment
so we have 29 schools
with instance running there's a couple
of schools where
if you look from the outside it does
look quite fragile in terms of the
number of bubbles that are going out
but again we're working really closely
with them with that
um so um the other thing to say is our
regulatory services have been
incredibly brilliant with the whole
concept tracing and do you go out to the
businesses as soon as we
are notified and also share in
intelligence back as well
the thing we have struggled a bit with
really which we're working with our
communications staff is around
self-isolation
so we've become aware of some families
and perhaps some
some age groups where they're not really
adhering to self-isolation
and that's really tricky it's tricky for
schools and how to manage that situation
and tricky for workplaces as well
so we're working with our comms team and
our partner to really push out that
message about how important
self-isolation is because i think the
message that eleanor is keen
and we are keen in terms of being a
public health team is that testing and
trace will only get us halfway there
it is around community engagement and
responsibility as well
um so that's a very uh quick update
there really around
um the contact tracing system okay
could i just ask in terms of um
you know hospitality um
when people you know go for meals and
to pubs and so on um
and how how did it actually work
if somebody you know go go
um sort of finds that they are
you know uh got covered and been tested
and then you know they go back to the
premises and how does it work in terms
of contacting everybody else
we had a case at the weekend of a
gentleman who
had had a test um
that had gone out for drinking a pub in
armstrong
and they had told us that they had been
there and could tell us exactly the time
and where they sat so we
rang the the landlord directly to advise
them and we were reassured with how the
landlord
um had managed and was managing in terms
of cleaning
and test and trace there have been
some um bars and pubs and restaurants
perhaps that haven't been as compliant
as we would have hoped
but our regulatory service and
information officers are going out and
working with them
obviously the announcement today changes
things
so things will be much stricter um in
terms of
face mask wearing and test and trace and
the launch of the app as well i think
the app is launched on the 24th where
all premises
will have to have um the i can never get
it right the q
code where you can scan your phone and
record tests and trace
um so again we have worked the gmp have
been really good
in terms of engaging with bars and
restaurants that they're aware of
our information offices and regulatory
so we have had quite a push on it but i
think
given the information we've had today in
terms of the announcements that will
change again
hey thanks sir councillor barclay
karen wanted to come in
yes yes please thank you chairman and i
think last time um when elena
was um with us and we discuss back
tracing
and trying to establish patterns of
transmission and obviously clearly it
seems that hospitality is one of them
i just wondered if there had been any
time to do any more work on that so that
we could
target our prevention a little bit more
in the right direction
thank you i think
we're still um really learning about
this
um partly because the contact we're just
picking up this contact racing and i
will hand it to helen and donna because
i've had two weeks holiday
so i'm still catching up myself i think
we are still seeing
in some cases that people aren't giving
as many contacts as we would expect
people to be having if you like so um i
think once we get when once our content
our local contact racing becomes a
little bit
um more robust uh and as we pick up more
from the national system i think we'll
be able to be asking more pertinent
questions
particularly about what people have been
doing as well as where
um where where people who who their
contacts might have been
so i'm really hoping that we start
getting more engagement with people
the other thing is that we definitely
know that we're seeing some people doing
if you like their own contact racing we
saw that early on with our 17 and 18
year olds
who clearly had all contacted each other
and we know we're seeing that again with
some of the schools
where people have come forward because
they wouldn't have been seen as contacts
from the school activity
but actually they've been able able to
identify out of school activity that has
meant that they have come forward
themselves
so we are seeing some very as well as
being seen some people who are really
resistant to self-isolation
and um who who probably aren't giving
the full story
we are seeing a lot of other people who
are being very very
responsible in how they're behaving and
again that's across the age range
so i i suspect that the other thing i
think with the hospitality industry
is that it can be quite difficult
to work out from a single case
where where that person picked the um
virus up from because they'll have a
number of different places they might
have been
including a number of different
hospitality settings um
and so it's much easier to start seeing
that contact racing
and and seeing that spread where you
have staff within the setting
and actually that same applies for
school so it's much easier to
to work out when if you have staff
affected
then who would who what who might they
have served and how do you
track those contacts rather than if you
like from the clientele
helen i don't know if you want to add
anything to that
no i think you covered it all but i
think also um
there's an element of case-by-case basis
so when we're seeing a number of cases
in a school
it's it's easy to go backwards as well
with some of them as well to work out
exactly what's
what's going on in terms of the
retrospective contact tracing
so we are doing it but um when we're
when there's more of a pattern i guess
is the answer
but we are engaged with the gm contact
tracing um
group so um we'll obviously raise this
with them and see
what advice they come back with
okay so any other questions
before we leave this item i was just
going to add actually just on
and it's not really contact racing but
it is about the advice to businesses and
so on and it's a bit like the advice
we've been giving to care homes about
not having um staff working in more than
one place
one of the issues obviously within the
workforce
is agency staff working in more than one
setting or where you have chains
of pubs or restaurants where people
maybe work
um in more than one of those settings
and we have seen some outbreaks
um linked to staff and staff movement
between premises as well
so again we've been working really
closely with those um
with our environmental health colleagues
and with the information officers to try
and support
um the businesses so that they can make
themselves as covered secure as possible
hello i didn't know if you wanted to
pick up about the new community
engagement group
as well yes so we have a new community
engagement group established
which i think really is going to help us
drive some of this
forward um because if this is going i
mean this is going to be going on for
the next six months and i think one of
the really helpful things from the prime
minister's statement today was
that this is a six-month plan this isn't
up and down
so i think that really will help us
think about how we manage
um how we manage how we how we um
manage risks and difficult situations
that i think all of us will be in
over the next six months and understand
the relative risks of different settings
um and and one of those risks is that of
course
um in if you're mixing with people that
you're close to if you're mixing with
your close friends and your family
you are going to be physically closer to
them you are going to you know that and
that does make that
transmission more likely so it really is
about trying to make sure that people
understand how to protect
themselves and and protect other people
and how we all
understand and apply those risks and try
and keep that
at particularly that two metre
distancing from each other um going
going through the winter while at the
same time um
going out and about enough to keep
ourselves physically fit and active
and mentally healthy so i mean it is it
is um
something we really need i think to be
thinking about with these community
engagement groups so that we really
understand what the pressures are
on people um and how we support them to
to make these next six months as easy as
possible for people
and and for people to be as safe safe
and well as possible okay i think
there's just one more
question last last one we'll have to
move on um linda blackburn council
thank you and i just wanted to to ask
alana
and the the carers who go from from one
client to another obviously where
ppe they are still at a risk
um to themselves particularly when
they're doing personal care
and i'm just sort of you know have a
concern obviously about them but
also the um the variety of
clients that they have and um you know
are we doing all we can to you know to
protect them
that's um really good question and
absolutely
absolutely vital and yes we are and we
are
we're working with our home care
providers offering additional infection
prevention control training
to um home carers because as you say
they are a group where they are um
both they may be at higher risk
themselves and obviously
there's that risk um you know they are
going from home to home
uh delivering absolutely essential care
so we're we're working with those
providers
and with the staff delivering that care
to really try and make sure that they're
as safe as possible
and they're absolutely up to date with
not only um
not only that they have the access to
ppe that they're wearing and usually
using it correctly and that they're
using all the other infection control
procedures
effectively and that they understand
those
um so that that's a yeah very very
important piece of work
and absolutely must not be forgotten
right thank you so much
can i thank uh councillor jane slater
councillor joanne harding eleanor
diane and helen
and donna uh for coming along
tonight to uh to to give us the update
and
to answer the questions uh we really
appreciate it but i'd like to
thank all of you um and
and obviously all the staff
that are involved and how incredibly
hard that you've all been working um
since this pandemic began
you know you've done incredible work and
you continue to do that and
with the enormous challenges that you've
you've faced
i think you've really come to the fore
in terms of
what what you've been doing and i think
it's
much appreciated by us as councillors
but uh i'm sure as the general public
you know really grateful for all the
work that you've
done carried out over those months and
we'll continue to do so
and i know how hard it has been uh for
for you all
uh so so just thank you so much
thank you and and and and we feel well
supported by
by yourselves and by by the wider team
in trafford so
um and that that really does help so
thank you and i'll pass the thanks on to
other people in the team who aren't here
today
i hope that you do do that yeah thanks
so thank you
um okay then uh i'll um
now move on to i can turn it uh
you're all welcome to go now by the way
because um we've just got a few items
that we'll
we need to discuss just tidy up uh
ourselves so thank you very much and you
can leave now
for thanks so item 10
um this really is
uh to to look uh moving forward
um and what items we want to um
put on the agenda um the the
there are two more meetings before
uh december and and we're looking
at the 22nd of october
and the 24th of november
and the but that has to be confirmed
by full council in september
because we're only scheduled up to uh
september
um but i think the constitutional group
panel had met and decided
um that we needed to continue with the
pandemic
committee and to review it at christmas
um and um
so as i say
there are provisional dates that i'm
giving you at the moment
but that needs to be confirmed at that
council meeting but also we
we need to fit in uh the budget scrutiny
committees and uh i've got a provisional
date of the first and the third of
december but i don't know whether that
still stands
um so so don't hold me to that
but he might want to just pencil it in
uh
your diaries um so i think
what we need to look at really
is um what we want to put on the agenda
for the next pandemic committee i know
that we have
this agenda setting panel which will
meet
tomorrow which is um
i think there's four of us on that panel
and
um and we'll finalize what the agenda
will
will be for that next meeting but i
think
uh as we've always done if you've got
any ideas of
what we need to put on the agenda it'd
be useful for us
to know that now but i i assume
that you know we'll continue with the
update
um you know of
the public health updates um
and probably the schools i don't i don't
know whether they want to
continue to put education
schools on the agenda i think they
they're more or less standard items
now um and i think um
the finance will probably take care of
itself but i don't know in terms of the
um that the two budget
scrutiny meetings that we'll be having
um in december
so for this next meeting
if we put on the public health for
definite
and an education stroke
you know schools um
and that's two items and if there are
any others
that we want to pick up on um
yeah bad yeah just
and also i mean one of the things that i
think
will become clearer is the schools but
i'd also be interested to see
how the homeschooling is doing whether
people are going back to school or in
fact more children are coming out
because i know there has been some
concerns
from parents about children going back
to school and i'm glad to see that we've
got
quite a number of children you know that
there's
a really good percentage um but also the
other thing is
um as well is that the ongoing
situation will have some effect on um
children's children and families as well
so it needs to be more
it needs to be looked at yeah i mean i
think uh
if we put um you know return to school
stroke education
um as an agenda item and then
we can have subheadings like home to
school
we can you know ho home
um yeah homeschooling should i say um
and um
and i think for for me i think
uh if we just for now
put put that as a heading um
and the subheadings will come and i
think if it any members who want to ask
questions anyway
it's you know we've kept that open for
all members if they wish to ask
questions and we you know we're happy to
um you know to to be
so if if we're happy with those two
items and then if there's anything else
that we would like to
uh the
children's and education stuff could we
have an update
on the ofsted i think we have mentioned
that yeah
and also i'm concerned about cams um
so perhaps if i could ask for an update
on that i think
um i did raise the question and they
they were keeping on top of the
referrals but i fear that now children
have gone back to school
and there will be an increase in
referrals i think
everybody's mental health has been
impacted by covid to some extent
um but i'd like to just make sure we're
keeping on top of that and
not just new referrals but also coping
with ongoing referrals and follow-up
yeah i think the other thing obviously
we've mentioned tonight and they're
going to do a report for
it anyways ehps
and you know we need we need to
um really find out and dig deep into
that i think
um so so
i think we can formulate some of those
questions
if we're happy to do that
and and any others that members might
wish to to ask to send them to herself
and
and alex um jane you wanted to raise
something jane dylan
thanks thanks dave and just following on
from what denise has said
in this pandemic scrutiny obviously
you've said it carries on until december
are we able to do any actual kind of
work
because i i find this quite frustrating
i find it really difficult
i feel like it's quite disjointed and
i just i just don't think we dig in as
deeply as we possibly could if we were
able to do
our other scrutiny with the task and
finish i'm
just i just i just feel that is the any
scope for doing
something i know that i've been in
discussions with denise about the cam's
work that we started
early on and we're gonna do that we're
gonna do that
a few of us anyway so if anybody would
like to volunteer to join and help us
please get in touch with denise as the
chair and but
is there any scope for us to do because
i just just find it quite frustrating
yeah i think i think um i think we all
find it frustrating because
there should be three committees
for one thing but the capacity is not
there
at this moment in time to be able to do
that but that's kept under
review and the next review will be in
december
um and that will look at um
you know the the the uh
three months up to april
uh january february march yeah um
uh so so if
if things change for the better which it
doesn't seem
likely that it will but if it did then
we would look to
try and get the three committees back
i think one of the things that we might
want to look at and i'd take a point
about the task
and finish group and they do work well
um but but again it will be capacity but
that it may be something that we can
look at
as a whole as a committee that
you know members do a piece of work on
on
single issues um but i think we need to
sort of
uh discuss with each other really how
best we can we might want to do that
so so i'll rate it tomorrow night
because we with that agenda setting
panel that we have um
we we we could discuss it there and see
what the scope is but it is up to us
really but
it is whether you know if you haven't
got the office of support it can be
quite difficult
the other the other thing that bothers
me about this way of doing it
is that we we're not able to get safe
for example if we're looking at ehcp so
the officers will come and give us their
side of things and we can question
however i'm interested in real evidence
which means real people real children
and it just seems that that isn't
something that we're
able to do with the format that we've
got the minute and i will shut up now i
promise
no no that's fine you know i i
understand exactly what you're saying
um um and i think we we
we do need a discussion in relation to
how we might
you know really um get down
into the heart of some of the issues
and that's an example of one um
i've got um karen
barclay and john
[Music]
thank you chairman there are just two
areas that i would quite like to kind of
just float as uh
topics for discussion one of them is um
how
we're managing our uh treatment of
cancer within
uh the borough because we know that
there has been a really significant
impact on that and i just wonder how
um how clinically that is progressing
and how we're catching up because that's
so crucial
and the other is dentistry which is a
kind of really kind of forgotten
area but has a lot of impact and a lot
of morbidity
and due to not being able to get to the
dentist and i just
don't know really how where we are with
that in the borough and i would
you know um if you just formulate a
couple of those
very simple we will get them over and
then
we can ask them to give us a report
um would that be okay
that's perfect i will do that thank you
okay
john john thanks david
um i'm just prompted to to make a
comment
from after listening to what jane
uh dylan was saying i think and i think
i've made the point before that
um i think to get some in scrutiny terms
we call them witnesses don't we you know
where
we get someone to actually tell us
as a committee the way they see things
the way they're experiencing things i
think this is what
jane is getting at and i think that uh
given the
you know the uh three or four main areas
that we're focused on
it it wouldn't be too difficult i don't
think and maybe this is for discussion
uh also tomorrow when we're thinking
about the program
uh for the program for the next
few meetings that you know we invite i
know there's always a difficulty about
you know a witness being representative
um
but if you think about you know the
local chamber of commerce for example
be interesting to hear what they're uh
sort of saying from their members
uh and uh i'm sure
they'll sort of you know think of other
suitable witnesses but
i think that'll be a way of us actually
you know digging down a layer or two uh
and actually uh probably
getting some insights into in into the
way this is being felt uh within
you know within the borough yeah i'm
conscious of the time and i think
you know the point that you made and and
i mean we
we can talk about this tomorrow because
i think um
you know we will have a bit of space and
just to knock it around a bit and see
what we can do and what we can't do
really and talking to our
um you know officers and
john and alex and you know
in terms of what support they could give
us in in terms of doing
things like that um
so yeah yeah
i just i just wanted to compliment what
jane
sort of said really and that i think at
some point we're going to have to
acknowledge
that it's quite unlikely that we're just
suddenly going to be allowed back into
the town hall and for everything to
resume as it once was
and with that in mind i almost wonder
whether
we will at some point need to have a
meaningful conversation about
returning to a mobile scrutiny
arrangement through this
sort of technological platform because
you know i think elena highlighted it
and the prime minister said today that
this is around for at least another six
months and i just wonder if we're sort
of kicking the cam down the road we've
said december and i think
i i'd be comfortable and i know that the
constitutional working group will have
this conversation as well
separately to this but i i think we need
to look at
alternative provision how we can um
return to
a more robust scrutiny arrangement now
really
because i think we're we're trying our
best with the pandemics routine
arrangements but
certainly i have no experience of
children's or health scrutiny
uh i i was on core scrutiny so i think
i can understand why people members who
have specific policy interests
to return to sort of the previous um
that's my opinion that's all thank you
yeah no that was fine
yeah and who else has
somebody else has asked questions
john john addison
[Music]
john addison
i think we're getting um to a point
really where
we've gone past our two hours i'm not
sure how long the
you're able to go on for so
if nobody else has got anything to say
that just one more
item and that is
a report to the executive which i i
[Music]
have circulated that report that
so so really it's just just to uh pass
that on to the executive but
obviously you're okay with it yeah is
everybody all right
okay and and we will have to you know
sort out a report really from this
meeting to go to the executive
as well because there's a lot of stuff
that we need to digest and then
put some kind of report together which
we'll do
do that over the coming days okay could
i thank you all
for your attendance and your patience
and uh
and i think again it's quite crammed
the meeting and i think that is one of
the
issues as well uh having one you know
pandemic
committee to deal with those items which
you
each one of them deserve a whole meeting
themselves really
but we just haven't got you know the
space or the time
um at this moment in time but you know
we'll work on that and see if we can do
things
differently at some point okay thanks
again
and have a good evening
[Music]
bye